I mean can I just lead with you were the
raddest looking human ever like what
like things I dream up in my head I'm
like I could try this like you pull off
all of them I just don't want to feel
like I look in the mirror and I look
conservative and straight I know
somebody you know like you know
sometimes they pass Brooks Brothers and
I think to myself well that ain't bad
I'm like what do you mean I like Brooks
player she and me too
but you know like really being in like a
pinstripe suit with like you know like
my real color hair which I haven't seen
since I was 9 I was I don't think you're
ever gonna be able to fight rock and
roll I think that's just gonna naturally
exude from you that's what we love about
you but you'll never met before
yeah we have you know in her show in my
show but I agree with you as soon as I
look too proper I'm like you know I
don't know what older artists look like
I feel like this like just not you look
beautiful you're not gold in what age
twine yeah I don't know I'm just I'm
gonna be basic Betty though even at 70
like I'm gonna I'm cool with it that's
who I am I'm like rolling with this
Cindy way what I always think of is your
song what doesn't kill you know that
softens I do I feel bored you know I
used to like whenever I was feeling
really kind of wide downtrodden I would
like I loved seeing along would even
hurt it you came a chick oh my god well
thank you okay I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this